die
[Musik]
frauen haben in der schweiz die gleichen
rechte wie männer so steht es in der
verfassung
[Musik]
die realität sieht anders aus
frauen erhalten weniger lohn weniger
rente ihre arbeit wird gering geschätzt
und viele von ihnen arbeiten gratis
diese frauen haben im alltag erfahren
wie hart das leben sein kann
doch diskriminierung und
frauenfeindlichkeit akzeptieren sie
nicht mehr gepunktet wenig flüssige
software wenn ich fest schaffen
fukushima scharf
außerdem haben alle voraussetzungen
ideal durch ständig sagte co-trainer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
spital wallis abstellgleis für natalie
uhr wieder 45 jahre alt ärztin und
ehemalige wissenschaftlerin natalie
urwyler hatte einst eine glänzende
karriere vor sich
die ausgebildete anästhesistin arbeitete
als oberärztin am universitätsspital
bern
sie war in der klinischen forschung
tätig und war auf dem weg zur professur
doch dann kam alles anders eigentlich
wirklich
und man hat mich messbereich gründet man
hätten rache kündigung ausgesprochen
höhepunkt von der diskriminierung
womacka veranlassen und das ist schon
sehr fertig meine ich habe alles
verloren
ich habe alles verloren weil ich ihm
ganze berufsleben treffen geschaffen
das berner inselspital anfang und ende
der karriere von magaly uhr wir elf
jahre hat die ärztin hier gearbeitet
hatte stets fachlich beste zeugnisse
generierte forschungsgeld und schaffte
es in einem hoch kompetitiven umfeld an
die ausländische eliteuni stanford
eine führungsfunktion und ich hatte es
nie in frage gestellt wieso dass frauen
in führungsfunktionen
seit jahren schließen mehr frauen als
männer das medizinstudium ab es gibt
mehr assistenzärztin als assistenzärzte
doch mit steigender hierarchie
verschwinden die frauen die spitze an
schweizer spitälern ist männlich auch
ärztin urwyler schaffte es nicht ganz
nach oben
mit der geburt ihres kindes war schluss
es klingt bedeutet heutzutage offenbar
wirklich immer noch ein bruch die
karriere von der frau und des
ratlosigkeit achtlosigkeit wird also
einfach und und frustration
[Musik]
sarah shuttle 47 jahre alt auch ihr
leben nahm eine abrupte wende bis vor
vier jahren war sie bäuerin gegen
reichenbach sich endlich mit mit
eigentlich bereits aus familie darauf
kann sich so gut ist machen sich weniger
gedanken
das ist schlecht nach 17 jahren verließ
sie den hof
[Musik]
sie hatte sich verliebt in jasmin die
reaktionen auf die liebe zu einer frau
seien teils heftig gewesen sagte die
ehemalige bäuerin richtig hart traf sie
aber etwas ganz anderes für bäuerinnen
gibt es nach der scheidung keine
finanzielle absicherung
obwohl in der landwirtschaft wie
anderswo in der gesellschaft rund 40
prozent aller ehen in die brüche gehen
[Musik]
auf diesem hof hat sara nardelli geliebt
gearbeitet und drei kinder groß gezogen
um die familie zu unterstützen haben
sich sarah shuttles eltern damals eine
wohnung gleich nebenan gekauft tochter
shuttle die kommt regelmäßig hierher zu
besuch
[Musik]
karl-heinz feiert geburtstag
die familie trifft sich häufig für die
kinder von sarah stähli sind die
großeltern wichtig sie sind eine art
bindeglied zur mutter nach der trennung
blieben die kinder auf dem hof und und
nach das ganze rechtlich kümmere wo man
eigentlich sauber ja nicht wirklich
große einigkeit equity fonds kommen bis
zu erschaffen
arbeit geleistet und danke aber dass das
mittel hoffe dass mir das wird wie oft
die landwirtschaft tickt anders bei
einer scheidung wird der hof also das
kapital und die eigentliche vorsorge der
bauern nicht geteilt so will es das
bäuerliche bodenrecht meist gehört der
hof dem man so auch bei sarah shuttle
eine obligatorische absicherung für die
frau gibt es nicht die eltern von sarah
shuttle die haben die trennung hautnah
miterlebt das ist froh sagte ja auch
noch ein 3 1 erzielt aber wirklich gar
nichts gutes das ist hat die versteckten
der global prestige effektives ob sie
was sie können und was nicht zu fassen
[Musik]
vor fünf jahren stand die narkose ärztin
natalie urwyler beruflich vor dem nichts
kurz nach der geburt von tochter nina
urwyler wollte karriere und mutterschaft
verbindung lang wartet mit dem kind aber
halt da immer wieder die frage von der
vorgesetzte oder der tu flackern oder
karriere und tosca das nicht gemerkt hat
mitleid mit bezug mutterschutz und
gleichberechtigung dafür hatte sich uhr
wie hier bei ihrem arbeitgeber dem
berner inselspital schon immer
eingesetzt
selbst davon betroffen kommt es zur
eskalation
urwyler akzeptiert die bedingungen für
den wiedereinstieg nach dem
mutterschaftsurlaub nicht nach der
geburt von wincanton höchster
schaftliche ticketnummer erlaubt mini
sämtlicher forschungsgeld gesperrt kann
ich habe kein zurückgriff mekka beruf
und der studenten unterrichtet mehr
annulliert und x6 für mich grundsätzlich
nicht gegangen dass ich aus - auch in
der forschung machen wo das ist ja der
sinn und zweck sie vom auslandaufenthalt
vom nationalen von stipendium monika
vorjahr und zurück betroffen muss land
das das sie hätten sie die richtig
geschafft
das inselspital bestreitet die
darstellung doch nur wie laviert sich
sie reicht bei der internen
gleichstellungs behörde von spittal und
universität beschwerde ein
wegen diskriminierung und verhinderung
der akademischen karriere
kurz darauf erhält sie die kündigung
begründung zitat das arbeitsverhältnis
zwischen ihnen und dem inselspital ist
aufgrund zahlreicher vorfälle über
längere zeit hinweg sehr belastet worden
das vertrauensverhältnis sei nachhaltig
gestört ich glaube ja wirkt dank des kec
was mit ihr passiert was dann passiert
sorgt schweizweit für schlagzeilen die
ärztin verklagt den grössten spital
konzern der schweiz wegen
diskriminierung und verletzung des
gleichstellungsgesetzes für mini lacht
wert aber ich habe gedacht ich habe hier
aufgrund von der schweizer verfassung
ich hatte aufgrund von relevant was 18
zu spital und universität bahn salbei
und ich habe der richter aufgrund von
gesetz wo man in der schweiz für den
mutterschutz
es ist nicht überliefert nicht nur dass
ich vier jahre lang volk so etwas ja
nicht gemacht aber für die graue eminenz
ist das schon sehr schwierig sieht das
jetzt halte meine frau sagt jawohl ich
mache das und pcs regimentes gesetz
würde man sich dann bitte vergleichen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
editha mit ihrem sohn samuel seit 18
jahren pflegt und betreut die mutter
ihren behinderten sohn unentgeltlich
samuel ist das jüngste von drei kindern
von geburt an war er anders als seine
beiden älteren schwestern was er hat
bleibt lange unklar
für mich steckt also maximal und nicht
geschlafen sondern als samuel sechs
jahre alt ist wird bei ihr eine
wahrnehmungsstörung diagnostiziert seine
entwicklung ist verlangsamt bei
kleinsten dingen braucht er immer wieder
unterstützung
[Musik]
samuels taktile und intermodale
wahrnehmungsstörung ist vergleichbar mit
dem verhalten eines autisten
er ist rund um die uhr auf betreuung und
pflege angewiesen
die hauptverantwortung für samuel hat er
immer mutter edith von samuels vater
liebte sie getrennt inzwischen ist er
gestorben
sie musste stets auswärts arbeiten
vor sechs jahren hat er die tanner einen
erschöpfungszustand lang suche sie wie
bringe ich meine antwort im sommer gegen
üblich und für antonia gegenüber um
minecraft und reinhard menschen mit
einer beeinträchtigung wie samuel haben
das recht stationär in einem heim oder
ambulant bei sich zu hause zu wohnen
für mutter edith kam das heim nicht in
frage sie fand keine angemessene
institution
bla bla bla das überhaupt nicht so
mancher tanz kinderlos lebenslauf das
ist dass wir wieder lernen laufen im
übertragenen sinn
weil samuel nicht im heim ist muss
mutter edith übernehmen
sie gehört damit zu rund 300.000
pflegenden angehörigen in der schweiz
die eines verbindet sie leisten
unendlich viel arbeit gratis auf ihre
kosten spart der staat milliarden
die mehrheit der pflegenden angehörigen
sind frauen für betreuungs und
pflegebedürftige menschen wie samuel
funktioniert die versorgung außerhalb
des heims in vielen kantonen nicht
lückenlos angehöriger springen 1
ohne menschen wie edith anna würde das
sozialsystem kollabieren der staat
rechnet mit ihrer unbezahlten arbeit
doch edith anna w nicht mehr dann kann
ich den gratis lotto jackpot ist war ja
nicht richtig ist dass es ist nicht
richtig dass der mutter von volljährigen
mensch immer so viel stunden
verpflichtet ist
frauen leisten hierzulande unmengen an
gratisarbeit ein exemplarisches beispiel
dafür ist die landwirtschaft 17 jahre
alte bäuerin schade lee auf einem hof
gearbeitet nach der trennung stand sie
vor dem nichts
vielleicht wenig plan der zicksee von
idylle und schön und gut mit punkt
sie sind sie aber oft nicht zwei drittel
der frauen in der landwirtschaft haben
keinen lohn
das heißt wie der
mutterschaftsversicherung noch sonstige
finanzielle absicherung sarah stähli ist
auf dem weg zur ehemaligen präsidentin
der schweizer bäuerinnen mit ihr will
sie den missstand bekämpfen
die diskussion ist wirklich für die frau
das sieht es so einfach ablehnen
nrw braucht es nicht und landwirte
schnitt existieren und es gibt
zusätzliche administrative verformt das
fing schon ziemlich dem aufbau zu sein
christine bühler bis vor kurzem oberste
bayer in der schweiz macht seit jahren
druck
sie will einen lohn für bäuerinnen und
eine soziale absicherung
doch die bauernschaft ist gespalten
betroffene frauen äußern sich häufig nur
anonym
bühler braucht frauen wie schade lee um
das problem sichtbar zu machen
und dass ich jeden hier unschädlich es
ist gut so wie sich das ja gut ablief in
die gesetzliche verankerung die muss
jetzt einfach mein gedruckt
das ist viel macht verfügen und hörzu
taxis und wenn sich die stelle sofort
gesellschaft und finden dass ich ganz
ganz schlecht bühler sagt in der
landwirtschaft von ein mann betrieben zu
reden sei realitätsfremd und
frauenfeindlich die arbeit von frau und
mann in der landwirtschaft müsse gleich
viel wert sein
das ist wirklich etwas auch nach dem
betriebsertrag politische und das ist
doch nicht das ist das ist schwingen und
dort wo sie knapp ist und woher und dem
vielleicht springt
und dadurch dass eindruck dass das thema
[Musik]
gleichberechtigung in der landwirtschaft
ein konkreter vorschlag liegt nun auf
dem tisch der bundesrat will eine
obligatorische minimale soziale
absicherung für bäuerinnen im gesetz
verankern
das parlament wird darüber entscheiden
[Musik]
edith anna und ihr sohn samuel die
mutter will erreichen dass der
18-jährige sind bestimmt in seinen
eigenen vier wänden leben kann ohne ihre
gratis hilfe kein einfacher weg richtig
aber auch moralisch sie habe immer
wieder zu hören bekommen
eine mutter mache das doch einfach
[Musik]
edita hat sich unterstützung geholt bei
einem anwalt in glas hardy landolt
professor für sozialversicherungsrecht
und tetraplegiker seit dem 14
lebensjahr hardy landolt ist
spezialisiert auf die komplexe thematik
von pflegenden angehörigen und betreut
viele ähnliche fälle wie den von editha
was braucht das zwischenstück formel
ruiz von der juristischen person zum
überhaupt das problem die iv bezahlt
zwar assistenz beiträge und hilflosen
entschädigung für die betreuung ihres
sohnes allerdings zu wenig damit er
unabhängig von ihr leben kann und die
spitex im kanton kann die pflege von
samuel nicht übernehmen für anwalt
landolt inakzeptabel dass angehörige wie
edith anna solche staatliche
versorgungslücken decken müssen häufig
vergoldet für sichere die leistungen
roma prämie zahlt damit mit geeigneter
versorgungsstrukturen bieten
das ist wie wenn sie
arztbesuch versichert sind und irgendein
kanton nicht sagen aber im kanton glarus
glarus arzt sie sind versichert sie
haben den anspruch darauf dass man die
rösterei benimmt und er bringt das staat
geleisteten aber erhöht und die dem
bereich sport natürlich brutal hart das
ist einfach völlig chips völlig erfahren
wo man da los zur lage ja frauen hat
mehrheitlich eine ganz schlechte
leistung bringen hardy landolt weiß
wovon er spricht auch sein eigener
ambulanter bedarf war nicht gedeckt
seine frau sprang ein
doch crystal kalender pflegt ihn nicht
mehr gratis
die ausgebildete pflegefachfrau rechnet
über ihre eigene firma an
für die akzeptanz dieses innerfamiliären
modells mussten sie bis vor
bundesgericht gehen
die beiden gingen noch einen schritt
weiter sie gründeten eine private spitex
und angehörige ohne pflegeausbildung
anzustellen
mittlerweile arbeiten bei der friedlich
spitex 15 angehörige
die firma rechnet jetzt ihre arbeit über
die krankenkasse ab auf diese weise
erhält die pflegearbeit der angehörigen
einen monetären wert das erkläre über
jahre vielleicht sogar jahrzehnte jetzt
erstmal lohnabrechnungen also handys
vorgestellt werden dass überhaupt ein
älterer wo doch im pflege- oder und
lacke farben kennt das also revidieren
ganz einfach ging das nicht editha
musste vor das kantonale
verwaltungsgericht damit ihr anspruch
auf pflege lohn anerkannt wurde
[Musik]
heute erhält sie von der friedlich
spitex 1200 franken pro monat einen
teilerfolg
sie pflegt und betreut ihren sohn noch
immer rund sieben stunden pro tag gratis
die entsprechenden klagen sind hängig es
gibt eine geringschätzung der arbeit
sobald sie die frauen machen
das bestätigen studien diese jungen
frauen wissen was es heißt im alltag
rebecca lüthi und camilla carboni sind
fachpersonen kinderbetreuung so genannte
fabi k sie arbeiten in kitas da sucht
liebevolle frau die gut klingen ganz
plump
ja und das ist nicht überall stieß
geschäftsführer ist mir wurde die jahres
billig macht einen pädagogisch
hintergrundwissen und dann ärgerte sich
schon es wird es aber gemacht so oder
situationen wenn ich zeit im zug saß ich
bin so herber wieso bist du jetzt mit
kind oder sprachlich arrondiert den
sinnen der ganztag und dann schwarz ich
gern
anstatt zu jammern über mangelnde
wertschätzung haben sie gehandelt
vor zwei jahren gründeten kita
mitarbeiterinnen aus zürich die
trotzphase die gruppe will die prekären
arbeitsbedingungen der kita branche
benennen und geht dafür auf die straße
heute bereiten sie transparente vor für
ihren nächsten termin den
frauenstreiktag mit kindern zu arbeiten
war camila carbon ist raubt mittlerweile
arbeitet sie nur noch als aushilfe in
kitas zu stressig zu unbefriedigend die
arbeitsbedingungen
wir dürfen camila carboni während zwei
stunden in einer städtischen kita mitten
in zürich filmen während dieser zeit
läuft alles ab wie im bilderbuch
situation
musik in mir ali die wirklich sehr
gezielt für den moment und der person
interaktion wird es doch während des
codes und als ich leider ganz höflich so
dass es um reinen ist und dass wir uns
nicht können so scharf wie immer nicht
gelernt hat und wie man geschafft hat
und das ist dann nicht wie alt ich sehe
inzwischen die zahl bringen wird das mir
drin hat zwar keine kraft für ihren tanz
zu viele kinder zu wenig personal eine
repräsentative umfrage der stadt zürich
aus dem jahr 2014 bestätigt diese kritik
in deutschschweizer kitas gibt es keinen
gesamtarbeitsvertrag vielerorts gelten
nur minimale bestimmungen des
arbeitsgesetzes praktikantinnen werden
als vollwertige arbeitskräfte eingesetzt
auch der lohn ist für die angestellten
minimal
es gibt keine verbindlichen vorgaben der
verband gibt suisse empfiehlt nach der
dreijährigen ausbildung 4000 bis 4200
franken einstiegslohn mit
berufserfahrung steigt er nur marginal
an der möglichkeit zum in gang bringen
und wenn das so die viel stein ich das
einfach mal ist pünktlich
ich mache das so nie mehr mit und hat
eine arbeitsbedingungen ist ein katalog
hören wir vielleicht noch länger oder
hebe und sage ja gut aber es ist
wenigstens wird es angemessen entlöhnt
aber wenn das nicht stimmt und ich
glaube es ist stickig bis vor kurzem so
sind natürlich in betreutes gratis und
auch er hat sich das zum glück für
andere das gibt es geht das mit wenigen
wir auch im geschäft oder das kita platz
gibt aber es hat sich louis van gaal
wirtschaft wird einfach ganz viel frau
ich krieg das negativ verloren und
schlechte arbeitsbedingungen und jetzt
irgendwie ja aber auf der suche
das ist eine wichtige arbeit geleistet
das sind kriegen tvo immer noch in der
gesellschaft nicht funktionieren sollte
funktioniert
und das sind fünf jahre als erste vor
ort wurden sind und ja die wertschätzung
die die zeigt sich auch die fehlende
wertschätzung verloren
die jungen frauen sind mit dem
selbstverständnis aufgewachsen für
frauen und männer gelten die gleichen
rechte wie schon ihr job hat sie gelehrt
eine abwertung ihres typischen
frauenberuf findet täglich statt für die
externe familienbetreuung braucht man
sieht zwar dringend
doch am liebsten möglichst günstig mehr
lohn mehr personal und keine billigen
praktikantinnen mehr mit unterstützung
der gewerkschaft vbio die sammelt die
trotzphase unterschriften für bessere
arbeitsbedingungen von kita angestellten
das kleid sie unnötig jeder tut es doch
lee nach sieben guten kamera und hat
zwar ich bin ich traurig sondern
[Musik]
dass das dauern kann bis ein
gesamtarbeitsvertrag steht darauf
stellen sich die frauen 1
denn dass es in sachen gleichstellung
einen langen atem braucht zeigt das
beispiel von natalie urwyler sie war
anästhesie ärztin am inselspital in bern
vor fünf jahren strengte sie einen
gerichtsprozess an der aufsehen erregte
feststellt hat es mir hinten camille
abily tät und die antenne spittaler
erfolg sollte hätte sich gleich stellen
auf eine andere echte sie da jetzt
eigentlich dass das fass zum überlaufen
gebracht und bei hätte das aber meiner
bewegungssprache zeit und dort konnte
entschloss kost und jetzt sagt jetzt ich
fasse belaufen ecm suite kommen jetzt
kommen vergleich ende 2014 klagt die
narkose ärztin gemeinsam mit ihrem
anwalt gegen den grössten spital konzern
der schweiz wegen rache kündigung
aufgrund des gleichstellungsgesetzes
gemacht
ich habe mir oder berater von der kanton
an der stelle für gleichstellung im
kanton bern war ganz ganz viel müsse
investiere die sache wirklich versuchen
christie's auch als forscherin natürlich
sammlerin und hat eigentlich sagt er bis
fuß und kann auch ein computer
elektronische datenbank mini cabrio für
millimeter dick sprachen so wichtig dass
man müsse die suche der höchste preis
ist ruhe konnte bewies das ist das
worauf geschrieben ist und auf das ist
ein prozess
das inselspital bestreitet vor gericht
die rache kündigung
schuld sei urwyler selbst mit ihrem
verhalten
sie sei illoyal nicht teamfähig dominant
und überschätze sich das
vertrauensverhältnis sei gestört darum
die kündigung
doch us-dokumente halten stand das
inselspital kann den vorwurf des
gestörten vertrauensverhältnisses nicht
beweisen
natalie urwyler erhält 2018 vor dem
obergericht des kantons bern auch
zweitinstanzlich recht das inselspital
hat der ärztin aus rache gekündigt weil
sie intern diskriminierung angeprangert
hatte und diese beschwerde hängig war
das urteil ist wegweisend
gleichbehandlung von mann und frau
dann muss man setze oder nicht umgesetzt
not umgesetzt und das finde ich das fing
aus jurist herrscht bedanken
mittelfristig sucht frau stehen die
zeichen des ebits krieg führt und sie
der hitze von hitze wenig wind
die die sozialromantische szenarios und
72 hat der nachtzeit der sammlerin die
werke nach oben grundlage für die männer
konnten als sie das ist ja permanent die
verletzung vom 16 das sieht natürlich
für mesum würde ich das hotel eigentlich
so gerechtigkeit das zählt jetzt griff
der x6 und gewicht verteilt betrieb
wegen der ankündigung was für mir jetzt
problem ist für mich persönlich hat es
nicht wirklich für konsequenzen
weihbischof und wieder freigestellt
wurde die dafür griffiger schaffen darf
nicht wieder wissenschaft machen also
mini karriere ist genau gleich ruiniert
wie sie vorher ruiniert iscsi und darum
ist
auf dem papier ist es kräftig hält aber
im war bereits mehr mitbrachte hoffe
aber dass es ganz ganz viele andere
frauen in zukunft hilft
[Musik]
natalie urwyler tat was viele frauen
nicht wagen anklage erheben gegen einen
übermächtigen arbeitgeber und
gleichstellung einfordern ich sehr gut
nachvollziehen wenn frauen mit welcher
tour über vierte macht mit dem protest
und allem was braucht unheimlich für
einen heimerfolg auf die unterstützung
von familie und freunden sei damals
zentral gewesen
allen voran ihr partner der arzt bruno
kämpfen für den bisher unterstützte mehr
mutige und rückseite des covers da
passiert so kann man mit frauen nicht
umgang und ohne ihn hätte ich das nicht
gemacht die wahl der fahrer gerade nach
der kündigung kleine war die woche
aussieht wird sie das durch horst evers
welle wäre mir sehr die die wohnung
verkäufer das wird investiert wenn das
kann die grenzenlos aber es wird im es
wird macht das geht einfach nicht dass
das hier in der schweiz durch wesley
tracht also verhandelt wird und die
karte wird und die schnitte gaga wäre so
unrecht zu recht wird wird widerstand
zutrifft die klage hatte für urwyler
knallharte konsequenzen
während des laufenden verfahrens fand
sie keine anstellung in der anästhesie
die habilitierte narkose ärztin fand
schließlich einen job am spital wallis
als assistenzärztin auf einem anderen
fachgebiet domenica weko chefarzt am
spital war damals mit verantwortlich für
ihre anstellung das gegen urwyler
lobbyiert wurde bestätigt er indirekt am
anfang vom letzten jahrhundert hat ein
waliser politiker namens moore ist treue
ich habe 50 jahren regierungszeit war
ein befehl von bank und muss
und nachher sind die befehle viel
weniger prägnant und den ihre macht
verloren
das waren immer im hauptportal
ich nehme diese person nur selber
nachstellen und schluss ist mir egal was
passiert ist diese person keine wahl
der sehr gute ausbildung person was darf
monitors laut dem moerser chance
hauptpunkt schluss und das egal und der
in ihr berührt das berner inselspital
bestreitet je gegen nathalie urwyler
lobby zu haben
das spital schreibt in einer
stellungnahme die aussage von chefarzt
rwe könne man zitat nicht nachvollziehen
[Musik]
auf jobsuche war vor vier jahren auch
die ehemalige bäuerin sarah shuttle
nach der trennung und dem weggang vom
hof war die berufliche zukunft ungewiss
[Musik]
nach tree monat vor der frage stehen
denn sexy stand tisch grund spricht ein
mystiker und gar ja ich habe mir im
normalen bewerbungsprozess missstände
offen
auf dem freien markt wieder beworben und
englisch weil die organe der
technikbranche verschiedenen
versicherungsbroker vertreten wir sonst
an zeitlicher aber schlussendlich
anfrage dass sie behauptet bis heute ist
sie leiterin von einem back office im
bundesamt für landwirtschaft
schadensfall ist eine ausnahme
zwar sind bäuerinnen gefragte
arbeitskräfte und finden nach einer
trennung meist rasch eine stelle doch
nur im billiglohnsektor ladies haut
ältesten dass papier geduldig ist und
der musikwoche die lebensläufe geklärt
ist und sich noch eine besonders
gelungene vorstellung als letzte
arbeitszeugnis irgendwie bizarr harisch
durch ja und referenzen was wohl für die
georgier vom nach bordeaux immer
schwingt sie nicht müssten die umstände
die man sich einfach so im
arbeitsprozess entsteht und wiederbelebt
ihre arbeit damals auf dem buch
mit familie und allem drum und dran gilt
offiziell als nicht erwerbstätig
finanziell wird das sarah shahi die
einst zu spüren bekommen wenn die nummer
traut weil ich es gut der junge gute
freundinnen also da wird die probe
negativ sage einfach aber wenn man nach
liebe lockt mit mit deiner ganzen
pensionskassen was mir fällt denkt
setzte die zukunft setzen auf ordnung so
rosig aus mit 47 jahren füllt sarah
shuttle jetzt ihre vorsorgelücken
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
schon einen minimalen ahv und
ergänzungsleistungen wird edith anna in
ein paar jahren leben müssen
die unbezahlte arbeit mit der betreuung
und der pflege von samuel hat massive
finanzielle auswirkungen auf ihre rente
abschied am bahnhof klaus einmal in der
woche geht samuel nach zürich in eine
möbelschreinerei es gibt immer mehr
momente in denen sich die wege von
mutter und sohn dank assistenten trennen
freiheit für beide die sich edita vor
gericht hat erstreiten müssen
davos
wow
unterwegs im zug wird samuel einen
seiner assistenten treffen
unabhängigkeit führen also dann möglich
wenn er normal produzieren
er will allein so dass das ist aber auch
macht sie ganz viel von mir auch viel
schwieriger und sinnvoll dass ich mich
wirklich auslaufen
er will und das wirklich auch wieder
autos ja selber samuel mit assistent ino
und schreine arno von handwerks-
kollektiv ist ein assistent von jan o
[Applaus]
aktuell hat samuel fünf assistenten
bezahlt von hiv den rest der
betreuungsarbeit übernimmt nach wie vor
die mutter unbezahlt als angehörige
bekommt sie von der iv keinen assistenz
lohn
mit arno schreiner samuel möbelstücken
diese kleine bank wird platz finden in
seiner eigenen wohnung
[Musik]
zwei klagen sind vor bundesgericht
hängig wenn die urteile zugunsten von
edel tanna und ihrem sohn samuel
ausfallen kann sie ihren gratis job
endgültig auflösen und der vierjährige
samuel mit hilfe von assistenten ohne
sie selbstbestimmt leben
bis es soweit ist wird sie kämpfen dass
ihre frau ab und so waren wir bestrebt
das problem der versorgungslücke sei
erkannt sagt der kanton glarus ein
betreuungs und pflegegesetz sei in der
vernehmlassung
ein gerichtsurteil ist schon zu ihren
gunsten ausgefallen ein zweites steht
aus die ärztin natalie urwyler hat das
inselspital bern aufgrund des
gleichstellungsgesetzes auch noch wegen
lohndiskriminierung angeklagt das
verfahren ist hängig
das inselspital sagt heute in den
letzten jahren sei viel in die
gleichstellung und in die vereinbarkeit
von familie und beruf investiert worden
mutterschutz gleichstellung und vielfalt
seien wichtige themen der inselgruppe
seit kurzem hat sich im berufsleben von
natalie uhr wieder einiges getan
mit der klinischen forschung ist es zwar
für immer vorbei aber nach fünf jahren
arbeitet sie erstmals wieder in der
anästhesie und sie wurde leitende ärztin
am spital wallis die führung immer dafür
ich wo er weiter horizont wo aber auch
vertreten ist großer fortschritt
wirtschaftlich auszahle
in ihrer neuen führungsfunktion will
urwälder verhindern dass fälle passieren
wie der ire oder derjenige ihrer
kollegin marita demichelis frauen die
zurückgedrängt werden sobald sie
schwanger sind und unter kriegen und
sich während dieser zeit nicht schonen
können auch demichelis hat das in einem
anderen spital liegt ich habe mich
damals um eine schwangerschaft und die
gesundheit meines kindes gekümmert
der große stress bei der arbeit war so
groß als 30 komplikationen bekam ich
habe entschieden mich nicht zu wehren
habe die karriere beendet und einen
anderen job angenommen
ich glaube es braucht mutige frauen die
machen was natalie gemacht hat und es
braucht die unterstützung der männer der
väter
um gleichstellung im alltag
durchzusetzen braucht es nicht eine
verfassungsgrundlage auch den druck der
betroffenen von frauen und von männern
politisch stehe sie nicht links sagt erz
die uhr wieder
doch sie die immer gegen eine
frauenquote war hat nach all den jahren
erfahrung in dieser hinsicht ihre
meinung geändert und man kommt es zum
beispiel täglich limitiere bis mittags
bis 50 prozent frauen in
führungsfunktionen herkömmliche wieder
abschaffen aber müsse dort einfach
korrigieren das appetit die graue
eminenz wo alle zwölf und trümmer
geraten sie in dem eine frau kam aus
heek macht entscheiden über ihre
karriere und böse lebensmodell ich
glaube dass nur mit überwinden
christian brix adecco im sinne jener ich
glaube jetzt bloß sanktionen
[Musik]
hochbeet stadt bauerngarten
das leben der ehemaligen bäuerin sarah
stähli hat sich stark verändert
neben der arbeit hat sie anfangs studium
in betriebswirtschaft und
wirtschaftspsychologie gemacht und vor
kurzem erfolgreich bestanden
sarah shuttle wohnt mittlerweile mit
ihrer partnerin jasmin zusammen auch
schade die steht politisch nicht links
doch seit sie als bäuerin erlebt hat wie
frauen sogar wirklich noch immer
abserviert werden schreibt sie die
frauenfrage und froh war dass man ein
problem weniger
es ist wirklich ein eher wahrscheinlich
ist das ja ich liebe fußball und ausgeht
sie eigentlich wünsche der frau haut
mutig und und harwich da und merke was
was was stimmt für mich und was stimmt
für mich und hat vielleicht ja mal
unkonventionelle wege einschlagen
[Musik]
[Applaus]